lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
simplificar nuevamente 3 por la raíz
principal de 500 por equis cúbica
tomando en cuenta algunos de los
comentarios que han dejado en youtube lo
cual nos permitirá dar una perspectiva
interesante de cómo simplificar esto y
recordando lo que hicimos en el vídeo
anterior
esto lo simplificamos como 3 por la raíz
principal de 500 y en este vídeo
pretendo hacerlo de manera distinta como
lo hice en el vídeo anterior para
hacerlo más interesante esto es 3 por la
raíz principal de 500 por la raíz
principal de x cúbica este 500 dado que
no es un cuadrado perfecto lo podemos
escribir como esto lo podemos escribir
como 100 por 5 o mejor aún lo podemos
escribir como 10 al cuadrado por 5
así es que nuestra expresión resulta
ahora
que multiplica a la raíz principal de 10
al cuadrado por 5 que multiplica a la
raíz principal de x cuadrada por x que
es lo mismo que x cúbica no voy a hablar
aún de cómo vamos a hacer esto diferente
eso lo haré después de que muestre lo
que hicimos anteriormente así es que
esto es 3 que multiplica a la raíz
principal de 10 al cuadrado que
multiplica a la raíz principal de 5
aquí estoy separando tengo la raíz del
producto de dos números es lo mismo que
el producto de las raíces de esos
números y esto que multiplica la raíz
principal de x cuadrada que multiplica
la raíz principal de x y aquí que
tenemos la raíz principal de 10 al
cuadrado es 10 y la raíz principal de x
cuadrada dijimos en aquella ocasión que
esto es el valor absoluto de x por si
acaso por si acaso el valor de x será un
número negativo ahora al simplificar
esto obtenemos 3 por 10 que es 30 luego
voy a intercambiar estos valores para
el valor absoluto de x que multiplica a
la raíz principal de 5 por la raíz
principal de x la raíz principal de 5
por la raíz principal de x lo voy a
escribir como la raíz principal de 5 por
x el producto de las raíces de 2 números
es lo mismo que la raíz del producto de
los números finalmente la expresión que
nos queda es 30 valor absoluto de x que
multiplica la raíz principal de 5 x esto
fue lo que hicimos en el vídeo pasado
ahora lo interesante es estamos tratando
con números reales entonces para que
esta expresión sea válida el dominio de
esta expresión son valores de x no
negativos es decir el dominio son los
valores de x mayores iguales que 0 deja
de ponerlo así mejor
el dominio el dominio es x cualquier
cualquier número real
qué es
mayor o igual a cero la razón de esto es
que si tú tienes un número negativo aquí
y lo eleva al cubo
vas a obtener otro número negativo y
para los números reales no vas a obtener
un valor aquí para los números reales no
está definida la raíz cuadrada de un
número negativo lo que hemos planteado
aquí es si estamos tratando con números
reales si nosotros consideramos que el
dominio son números complejos ahí sí
está definida la raíz cuadrada de un
número negativo sin embargo para los
números reales con los que estamos
tratando este no es el caso así es que
el dominio es cualquier número real que
es mayor o igual a cero y entonces el
valor absoluto de x tiene que ser x así
es que suponiendo que solo estamos
considerando valores de x que son
válidos para esta expresión el resultado
de simplificar esto sería 30 por x por
la raíz de 5 x si fuera el caso que
estamos considerando números complejos
está entonces sería la solución si no
sabes lo que son los números complejos o
los números imaginarios no te preocupes
por eso
si los estuviéramos considerando
tendríamos que mantener el valor
absoluto de x porque entonces esta
expresión si estaría definida si estaría
definida para números que son menores
que 0